- [Voiceover] California is experiencing
its most serious drought in decades.
In about a year, the state's
reservoirs could run dry.
This is a serious crisis.
Here's what Californians
are doing to make a change.
- I really care about the environment,
that's why I only eat locally grown food,
like this almond.
- [Voiceover] But it takes
about 1.1 gallons of water
to make one almond,
and that doesn't help because
it was grown in California.
- Yeah, but isn't the most important thing
just to eat local?
- [Voiceover] No, not in this instance.
- Does it help that I'm vegan?
- [Voiceover] Let's move on.
Let's see what this couple's
doing to make a change.
- I'm taking my girlfriend on a picnic,
but instead of taking three jugs of water,
I'm only gonna take two.
- [Voiceover] Why would you need
that many jugs of water
in the first place?
- In case we get thirsty,
or we decide to have a water fight again.
Babe loves water fights.
- [Voiceover] This is literally
the worst possible time to--
- Water fights are great.
They're fun.
Aren't they fun?
- Yeah, so fun.
- Do your water fight thing.
Show the water fight thing.
But there's like a water balloon.
It's so cute.
- (laughs) It's so fun.
- It is so cute.
- [Voiceover] OK, while that is adorable,
we need to be making
more conscious efforts,
like turning off the water
when we wash our hands,
or taking shorter showers,
like this woman.
- To conserve water,
I'm only taking showers
for five minutes tops.
- [Voiceover] And she's starting today.
- Well, actually I'm probably
gonna be starting tomorrow
'cause I've got a huge date tonight,
so probably gonna be at least 40 minutes,
if you know what I'm saying.
- [Voiceover] OK, this
last guy, he's normal.
What are you doing to end
the water crisis, sir?
- A drought?
I thought this was an
audition for The Walking Dead.
- [Voiceover] No, I said if we didn't do
this PSA, we all might be dead.
- I still get paid though, right?
- [Voiceover] You know what, I quit.
I quit.
("Innovating the Future")